this video is brought to you by
curiosity stream
[Music]
hey what's up wisecrack greg edwards
here look ever since the tonight show
aired in 1954
the american late night talk show has
been as ingrained in american culture
as baseball apple pie and using super
soakers to drink tequila
or hot summer days and no one has done
more to demean this hollowed format than
comedian eric andre
who has used the genre to leave a trail
of horrified celebrities
befuddled pedestrians and decimated
wooden desks in his destructive wake
but is there more to the bizarre antics
and his pension for being gross as hell
is this really just a way to smuggle a
deeper message to his viewers
let's find out in this wise crack
edition on the comedy of eric andre
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
curiosity stream
if you're looking for more content to
binge this summer look no further
curiosity stream has thousands of
streamable documentaries
and non-fiction tv shows on history
nature
science food technology travel and more
they feature shows from some of your
favorite smart channels while also
hosting exclusives
and curiosity originals right now i'm
watching dream the future
with sigourney weaver a series that
explores how technology shapes us
and how the future may be impacted by
our innovators
i love that curiosity stream is
available on most devices including
apple
android and your smart tv so you can
watch anywhere
anytime if you click the link in the
description or go to curiositystream.com
wisecrack right now and use code
wisecrack
you can get a whole year for just 14.99
you can cancel at any time so what's the
risk check it out by clicking the link
below
and now back to the show here's a quick
rundown for the uninitiated
andre is a stand-up comedian during
racial sensitivity training
he started saying the n-word like crazy
they're like dude they're supposed to
have the opposite effect
papa actor how did you learn to do that
what the same way everybody learns the
day i hit puberty wizard appeared and
taught me a dystopian talk show host
who since 2012 has hosted the eric andre
show on adult swim
with his sidekick the hilarious hannibal
bars it features a mix of in studio bits
[Applause]
interviews you ever heard of a robot
before i don't even know what that means
hidden camera pranks
i'm mr burrito the human pizza we spoke
earlier i'm from the pizza society and
i'm here to talk to you about pizza
safety
and the occasional musical guest
it's often very weird usually very funny
and if you watch an episode with your
stepmom girl she'll be very confused and
extremely concerned
but gayle can be assured that andre is
doing more than just goofing around
in fact he's working in the vein of a
tradition first used to describe gross
looking roman ruins
and later applied to everything from
weird gargoyles
to carnival freak shows the grotesque
while the grotesque was once used as a
way to strike the fear of god
into the illiterate masses with this
nightmare fuel
it really became what we know it as
today at the turn of the 20th century
when italian playwrights created
what critics call theater of the
grotesque
the grotesque is more than just being
gross it's about transgression
by pushing boundaries and celebrating
the abnormal it helps us better
understand
our allegedly normal world andre is far
from the first person to use the weird
and uncomfortable
for cinematic effect filmmaker john
waters put his name on the map for
among other things making a movie where
the main character eats
dog then there's david lynch who was
more partial to severed ears
but in andre's case the normal world
he's transgressing
is the celebrity world and what better
microcosm of that
than the talk show in doing so he wants
us to question how
normal the entertainment world is after
all
you only need to look as far as the
opening credits to know that the eric
andre
show is going to be a million middle
fingers to jay leno and jimmy fallon
and all their guests where a traditional
show has a house band playing crowd
pleasing jazz
andre's house band ops for the john was
discorded and chaotic cousin
[Music]
[Applause]
where a traditional opening credit
sequence might have some b-roll of the
host
or a city skyline andre uses this time
to psychotically destroy his set
and occasionally get his sex club raided
by the feds
hey the atf's here
while this might seem bizarre and
arbitrary it destroys the illusion of
normalcy that surrounds the late night
format
giving the audience a taste of what's to
come the same can be said of andre's
interviews with celebrity guests
during which he'll do anything from set
of rat loose
what's going on to pretend to actually
pee his pants by making these interviews
as weird and unpredictable as humanly
possible
andre is transgressing the normal
formula for
how a host is meant to interview guests
a formula defined by pre-screened
softball questions
clear setups for plugging their newest
product or film
and so on are you proud of it are you
aware of how good it is
and in doing so andre exposes just how
meaningless scripted and sometimes
straight up stupid
these interviews and other talk show
tropes really are is shooting up your
onstage
band really any more fake than rehearsed
pleasantries
alright maybe it is a little more fake
but still
and while it might at times seem like
he's just being a dick
according to andre it's not just about
making somebody uncomfortable
or harassing somebody or giving somebody
a hard time
i set out to be the most incompetent
talk show host of all time
it's more about blowing the guest's mind
having them feel sort of an out of body
experience
he's the morpheus of pop culture if you
will but andre isn't just transgressing
the polite handshaking of meeting
jennifer lawrence
on the tonight show by pushing
boundaries in his real world stunts
we can start to ask similar questions
about the lines he's crossing there
take the time that eric ran through a
civil war ringing magnet as a shackled
runaway slave
and because andre has a tendency to push
the line until he can't push any further
there is a slave catcher chasing them
with the whip
while andre's stun is certainly weird it
forces us to ask more basic questions
like
isn't it more weird that people do
historical reenactments without
addressing
certain conveniently omitted details
andre even said in an interview that the
idea came to him after seeing the ad for
colonial williamsburg
where are all my black brothers and
sisters getting their reenactment
on and then i was like oh yeah black
people
weren't having a good time in the real
colonial williamsburg
is andre the weird one or is it the
people who dress up as soldiers
defending slavery
by disorienting our perception for a
second we're able to see the situation
for what it really is
[Applause]
look i don't know about you but i like
to dress up as a member of the chilean
death squad on the weekends you know
for the history if most art is an active
expression of norms like
norman rockwell painting celebrating the
joy of getting together and murdering a
nice juicy turkey
the grotesque is about questioning those
norms at every step
andre is trying to achieve something
similar when he runs into a tea party
meeting to kindly let the attendees know
excuse me you guys forgot your hoods it
might be absurd to jump on the stage and
alex jones
man and then self-identify as a
knowledge i'm not a
democrat either i'm a nihilist but we
can also ask
isn't jones brand of snake oil fueled
conspiracy politics
deeply nihilistic in the first place we
might compare andre's out-of-studio
antics to those who say
david letterman leatherman broke up the
monotony of studio time with almost
purposely
non-confrontational humor like strapping
a camera to a roller skate monkey
are literally dropping random things off
buildings utterly devoid of any iota of
social commentary
these stunts are put in stark relief by
the wild
incendiary political acts andre
incorporates into his show
by turning of an all reenactment our
political rally into a situation that
feels abnormal and unstable
we're forced to see the normal in a
whole new light here's my hotel kit i
want you to have sex with my wife
it's like how if you drop acid before
you watch the 1998 remake of the parent
trap
you realize that it's actually a film
about how all americans have a split
consciousness
on one side we're rugged american
individualists and on the other
british knobs and those halves are
always trying to reunite
so that our parents will love and accept
us we actually
did it but you didn't think we were
going to skip the real
nasty [ __ ] did you i mean
quite literally this is a bag
[Music]
eric andre has a deep love for all
substances capable of being
expelled from the human body take the
iconic example of andre's interview with
lauren conrad
star of mtv's the hills her publicist
clearly hadn't done their homework
as from the moment she walks on set
she's visibly uncomfortable
but always wanting to be a good host
andre goes the extra links
to make sure she's relaxed by vomiting
on his desk
and then eating it in front of her in
case you miss that
he first pukes all over his desk and
then he tries to subtly eat the puke
conrad responds by getting the hell out
of there
so is there any way to explain this that
doesn't end with and that's why
eric andre is a disgusting human who
never should have been given a show and
instead of watching it we should all
just watch reruns of ellen a host we can
admire for her kind treatment of others
here's what andre later recounted in an
interview about conrad
i'm not trying to be a dick she's cool i
have no beef with her
it's just you know i'm a psychopath when
i'm doing the interviews
oh she doesn't take it personally but
she didn't like it too much
here's the deal we walk around in our
day-to-day lives
wearing clothes eating well-prepared
meals and
wearing masks over our disease holes
trying to forget that underneath
all of our civilized practices we are
animals that fart
and burp and piss and protect our vomit
at brittany johnson's 9th grade party
even worse andre invokes this humbling
embarrassing feeling
in front of quote-unquote celebrities
their entire careers typically depend on
our belief
that they are larger than life that they
almost certainly transcend the
disgusting reality
of their farts loudly reverberating in
the toilet bowl and to share it off his
bathroom
sorry jared my bad all right
what's more he does so on the squeaky
clean suitclad turf of a talk show
where hosts focus on family friendly
zingers and
topical but not edgy commentary it's
also worth mentioning that late night
host jack parr got in trouble
for making a joke about the water closet
in 1960
by contrast andre spent an entire year
not grooming himself
before the filming of his fourth season
not even letting the costume department
ever wash his suit like james corden
singing carpool karaoke
andre is reveling in his own filth but
all of that said is eric andre gross
hell yes a hundred times yes he's so
gross
and it's shocking that he's been able to
land so many seemingly normal
romantic partners like rosario freaking
dawson
who is now dating senator cory booker
andre
is gross but he is using this grossness
to create his own theater of the
grotesque
in which he is pushing boundaries and
testing limits to make us think about
how weird and often disgusting
our supposedly normal world is and just
like a batch of your cousin scott's
special brownies
the eric andre show is able to blow our
minds and make us see
things in a whole new light so next time
someone calls you weird
for eating an ice cream sandwich in the
shower are gross for throwing up all
over wall street
or a criminal for having a contest to
see how many babies you can hold
you can respond by simply explaining
that like eric andre
you are an artist using the grotesque to
push the boundaries of experience
but what do you think wisecrack is he
just a nasty ass comedian
or is there a method to his madness big
thanks to our patrons for supporting our
channel
and the podcast hit that subscribe
button and as always
thanks for watching peace
[Music]
you